to the pictures now coming in from  argentina where the country's vice  president narrowly escaped an apparent  assassination attempt overnight we  should emphasize she is okay but take a  look at this video which shows a man  pointing a gun  just inches from the head of christina  fernandez de kirchner after she got out  of a car to greet supporters according  to argentina's president the suspect  pulled the trigger of this loaded  handgun but the weapon did not fire it  jammed  the shooter was quickly arrested at the  scene the vice president a divisive  leader in south america was previously  uh the president of that country and is  currently on trial facing corruption  charges there in argentina but wow those  pictures makes you wonder about security  doesn't it the gun to the security mad  at her just the fact that they could get  that close i think is very frightening  because you can physically see the gun  and you can even see him pull the  trigger yeah  all right lucky lady